the movie is set in the 16th century in
the opening scene we are introduced to
Tien the youngest son of a noble family
from the ayuthaya kingdom he is
currently held captive by soldiers under
the command of Lords rosh hashina Tian
appears to be heavily sedated and he
only wakes up with several buckets of
water are thrown into his face the first
thing he sees is a group of soldiers
armed with thick wooden staffs and it
becomes apparent that a judgment has
been passed on Tien and the soldiers are
instructed to brutally beat him up as
they get ready to begin the procedure
Tien gathers all of his energy and
fights back with his impeccable moves he
takes out many soldiers but eventually
gets overpowered and knocked out after
this rajasina orders his men to break
tien's elbows and knee oh God on the
other hand the village of kanakone is
grappling with an outbreak of illness a
local doctor attends to a few patients
while the villagers claim that the
illness is a curse in order to seek a
solution for the same thing a master
named bua leads a Buddhist pilgrimage
during which he discovers that the
source of the curse is booty senka the
dark Mystic or the devil of Darkness
with a nice booty Master bua then
channels the malevolent energy into a
single leaf that lands in his hand after
this he decides to become a monk to
fight against the evil forces elsewhere
rajasina is haunted by visions of his
deceased predecessor whom he had
poisoned to death in order to take over
the throne these Visions torment him and
it becomes clear that rajasina is
suffering from a curse placed upon him
by the late King before his death later
at midnight rajasina wakes up only to
discover that there is a fight going on
in his Courtyard it appears that some
soldiers have come to rescue Tien from
his captivity but right then booty
arrives out of nowhere and eliminates
the soldiers one after another after
witnessing his remarkable combat skills
rajasina offers to hire him hoping to
secure his Services however the dark
Mystic is something else in his mind he
instead suggests removing rajasina's
curse implying that there is a
connection between the curse and Tien
the evil Lord believes it right away and
orders his men to finish off Tiana
however just as the Executioner is about
to strike a messenger from the ayathaya
kingdom arrives with a pardon for Tien
granted by the highest Authority in the
land this leaves rajasina with no choice
but to relinquish his prized prisoner as
he shouts in Anger he experiences a
sudden hallucination rajasina sees his
soldiers coming towards him seemingly to
execute him this frustrates him so much
that he snaps out of his vision and
impulsively kills one of his soldiers
that's how you know he's a bad guy
meanwhile Tien is rushed to the Village
of kanakon in order to receive the
necessary healing his beloved girlfriend
from childhood Pim is assigned to take
care of him but before the healing
process can even begin they come under
sudden attack from masked assailants
sent by rajasina as chaos ensues a
fierce fight ensues between the masked
man and the Royal Messengers The Evil
guys quickly gain the upper hand and
start assassinating the poor people one
by one but they are eventually thwarted
when the remaining Messengers team up
and fight with all their might at last
all the masked men are slain but so are
The Messengers in the next scene we find
Tien lying on a stone bed his body
wrapped in bandages as a testament to
the injuries he has sustained Master bua
having returned from his meditative
State reveals that tien's current state
is the consequence of his negative of
karma from the past Master bua then
calls upon the entire Village so that
they can pray together and heal Tien
back to life the process involves the
creation of the Sacred ongbok Buddhist
statue heartfelt prayers offered to the
deities and the administration of Herbal
Remedies just like when people send
thoughts and prayers on Facebook in the
midst of all these healing practices Pym
who is driven by her love and devotion
for Tien performs an enchanting prayer
dance seeking help for his fast recovery
thankfully their combined efforts yield
a positive outcome as T Henry gains
Consciousness but due to his brutal
beatings he is unable to get to his feet
at the break of dawn Tian drags himself
towards a nearby Cliff he wants to
commit the unthinkable as he feels
hopeless both physically and mentally
but right then Master bua arrives at the
scene and stops him he initially scolds
Tien for escaping from his duty of
saving the kingdom and its people then
he redirects his attention towards the
Rising Sun Master Buddha
a profound lesson saying that even in
the darkest of times light is ever
present waiting to dispel the Shadows
stirred by these words Tien gets
motivated to continue living so he
reconsiders his decision huh I never
thought about sun and shadows before
from that day forward he undertakes a
grueling Journey he drags his weakened
body to an abandoned Temple nestled deep
within the woods and begins
self-medication he also stretches his
muscles and contorts his bones in an
attempt to get himself back to his feet
as time passes tien's body gradually
responds slowly recovering its strength
and resilience one day Pam arrives at
the temple to see him she mentions that
she missed him a lot and was praying
every day for his recovery hearing this
Tien becomes overwhelmed with happiness
so he asks her for a dance and after
their romantic session they stand on a
rocky Cliff embracing each other on the
following day Master bua approaches Tien
and tells him about Dharma which
includes the prince of righteousness
Merit and fulfilling religious and moral
obligations it can also teleport polar
bears to Tropical Islands with this
lesson in mind Tien goes on a
transformative Journey he practices some
spiritual dancing moves and trains
himself to develop a new fighting style
by combining martial arts and dance and
as the days pass he transforms himself
into a formidable Beast capable of
taking down anyone elsewhere rajasina
pays a visit to Booty's ruined Castle in
order to break free from the curse that
has plagued him however Booty unveils
his true nature revealing that he was
the one making him suffer all along he
also mentions that his ultimate goal is
to become the new king the tour King
hearing all of this rajasina becomes
enraged and He commands his men to kill
booty but despite the combined effort of
the soldiers they proved powerless
against the formidable dark Mystic booty
showcases his extraordinary combat
skills swiftly taking down the soldiers
one after another in the end rajasina is
left alone so he clutches his bow and
arrow and directs it towards the
betrayer however before he can take the
shot booty gets to him first and
decapitates him the severed head curses
booty just like the previous King had
bestowed upon rajasina but the dark
Mystic appears to remain unaffected
later he ascends to the throne and
seizes control of the Kingdom now with
only one remaining adversary Booty
dispatches his soldiers with the mission
of eliminating Tien that evening as Tien
is in the middle of his training he is
unexpectedly confronted by the group of
soldiers they are desperate to kill him
and please their new master however Tien
has other plants with the help of his
new fighting skills he takes out the
enemy soldiers one after another without
even breaking a sweat it appears as if
Tien has finally mastered the art of
Dharma through tireless dedication and
discipline practice following this Tien
quickly makes his way towards the
village of Khan
only to discover a harrowing sight the
once thriving Village Now lies in Ruins
its streets stained with the lifeless
bodies of the villagers the site breaks
Tien mentally and he starts crying like
a little baby boy bilge however his
Solitude is disrupted once more as a new
wave of enemy soldiers comes running for
him they are confident that they can
kill Tien but little did they know that
they have angered the deadliest fighter
in the world driven by a burning desire
for vengeance he end channels his anger
and teaches these soldiers a hard-earned
lesson once he is done killing them the
end performs a final ritual to honor the
Fallen villagers paying tribute to their
lives following this he meets Master bua
for guidance the latter gives him a few
words of encouragement and handsome a
mystical stick which is capable of
defeating the darkness Master bua
explains that the stick is the most
powerful weapon in the world and if used
properly it can even summon the god
elsewhere in Booty's Kingdom we learned
that Pym and the remaining villagers
have been enslaved they are compelled to
work as laborers in extremely harsh
conditions if they make even the
slightest of heiress or feel tired the
soldiers mercilessly beat them up with
whips the situation of the royal
elephants is even worse they are
brutally killed for the sake of their
blood which is consumed by booty to gain
extra strength in the meantime Tien
arrives at the Kingdom determined to
free his people and defeat the enemy
however booty senses his presence and
decides to take action in a shocking
Display of Power and Magic he summons an
Eclipse which plunges the kingdom into a
state of total darkness this makes the
villagers realize that he is no ordinary
man so they bow before him in fear
unfortunately booty gets to know the Pim
is tien's lover so he quickly grabs her
and finishes her off this is enough to
send Tien over the edge and in an act of
desperation he unleashes a Savage
Onslaught against the guards he then
tries to kill
but the dark Mystic quickly turns the
tables and plunges a spear deep into
tien's chest leaving him on the brink of
death as tian's life Fades away he
remembers Master Buu's teachings and
suddenly the entire battle as well as
pym's tragic demise are revealed to be
Just an Illusion now having been given a
second chance he then decides to do
things differently it's time to Clap
That Booty he uses the power of His
magical stick to summon the Thunder and
strike booty this decisive blow shatters
the devil's Powers which ultimately
causes the eclipse to go away
symbolizing the Triumph of light over
Darkness as booty wakes up from the
strike he is unable to believe that his
demonic powers are slowly fading away
before his very eyes soon Tian confronts
him and the final showdown between the
two finally commences here we see the
Tien is not fighting in Anger like he
did in his illusion instead he appears
to be calm focusing on his newly
acquired skill at 1 point during the
fight booty launches his spear hoping he
can defeat his opponent once and for all
but to his dismay Tien is able to catch
it with just his bare hands after this
the Fight Continues for a while and both
of them end up on the Royal ledge above
the arena they appear to be equally
matched when it comes to fighting but
when it comes to concentration Tien has
a massive Advantage sensing the
environment around him he cleverly holds
booty Aloft by his chin and drops him
over a furious elephant the animal's
Tusk breaks and mortally impales booty
penetrating those sweet cheeks and
finally killing him in this way the war
comes to an end and the kingdom is
finally freed from all evil the movie
ends as we see Tien Pym and the
remaining villagers paying their
respects to the revered ongbok Buddha
statue they are now hopeful for starting
a peaceful life where no evil or curse
can disturb them subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching